all right today
we are going to be talking about nfts
what are they
how do they work what the hell does it
even stand for we're going to get to all
of that in just a second this video is
sponsored by our friends
over at giant partners alrighty so n
f t s so here's the thing about digital
space pretty much everything
sounds as though it is some sort of
bureaucratic government agency but but
an nft actually is a non-fungible token
they're putting the fun in non-fungible
token so
what exactly is a non-fungible token
well fungibility in this iteration just
means
that one item is equal to another item
it's equivalent
they're interchangeable so for example
bitcoin is funchable because when you
have a bitcoin
that bitcoin is interchangeable with any
other bitcoin
but when you have an nft it is a unique
piece of intellectual property
and it is not in fact interchangeable
with any other piece
of intellectual property it is unique
like a piece of art
so in the same way the nedvard monk
painting of a weird person screaming
would be like would be
non-fungible with the mona lisa which
i'm not even going to attempt to draw
you can exchange value for each of these
but it's more like a piece of art
the best way to think of how you
establish authenticity in an nft is sort
of like a certificate of authenticity
you get when you buy a signed baseball
or when you buy a piece of art
except here the blockchain gives you a
unique code the best way to understand
what an nft is is to think of a baseball
card
what makes a baseball card actually
worth money it's just a piece of
cardboard right with a picture on it
now theoretically you could just create
a knockoff piece of cardboard with the
exact same information on it
and you could just print it out on your
computer you can make it look identical
to the original tops baseball card and
it would not be worth what the original
card
is worth and even the picture right i
can get the picture online i can look at
the picture online
i can theoretically license the picture
online and use it elsewhere
so what exactly makes that baseball card
unique and the answer is
whatever people think is unique and a
value is unique and of value just like a
piece of art right a piece of art
is just the artist putting a bunch of
paint on a canvas what makes that
inherently valuable that everybody else
thinks that it's valuable
this by the way should in its most
obvious state
reject the labor theory of value the
marxist and ricardian
labor theory of value suggests that you
can tell the value of an object in some
sort of objective way
by looking at the amount of labor that
went into the object the subjective
theory
of value which is proposed by the
viennese school of economics says no
value lies and what people think is
valuable well obviously when you talk
about a baseball card when you talk
about a piece of art
the latter is true because i could throw
paint on a canvas the same way as
jackson pollock but my painting ain't
going to be worth 2 million bucks
so it is the vision of what the value of
the object is worth that makes the
object worth anything
now sometimes these items retain their
value sometimes they do not now a
certain level of exclusivity
provides for greater value scarcity in
the market tends to provide for greater
value if you've got a honest wagner
baseball card
then that's worth a lot of money because
there are not very many of them on
planet earth
if you are like me and you grew up with
parents who grew up in the 1960s all of
them have stories about how they had
baseball cards when they were kids and
then like idiots they put them in the
spokes of their bicycle wheels and now
they're worth nothing but if they'd kept
their baseball cards they would have
been worth a hundred thousand dollars
okay so all of us when we were kids in
the 80s and 90s we went out and we
bought like full sets of tops
the problem is everybody had the same
idea so those baseball cards aren't
worth very much money you can have a
frank thomas rookie card might be worth
a couple hundred bucks it is not going
to be worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars the way a mickey mantle baseball
card is going to be worth
because of scarcity but you can
certainly have situations in which
objects once have value and then lose
the value when for whatever reason
people decide they actually don't care
about them so for example the most
obvious example of something like this
is of course the beanie baby if you are
old enough to remember the 1990s
and now i'm dating myself god we're
getting old here if you remember the
1990s beanie babies were a thing i
remember my grandmother buying beanie
babies
for the kids and then handing them out
as though this was going to be their
life savings these beanie babies some of
these things were going for like
thousands of dollars you had a rare
beanie baby she was like don't take off
the tag
if you take off the tag the beanie baby
loses it's valuable now these are things
that my kid plays with my baby
i just gave give it the baby baby chews
on it because they're not worth anything
my beanie babies didn't retain their
value because nobody thought
the beanie babies were valuable anymore
the only thing that separates baseball
cards from beanie babies is a lot more
people like baseball than like beanie
babies
so what does this mean to me it means
that certain
nfts certain non-fungible tokens will
retain value over time but only if they
remain artistically durable
only if people continue to care about
them we're gonna get to more about nfts
in just one second first i want to tell
you about our friends over at giant
partners now don't hit fast forward i'm
going to tell you a little bit
about the origins of daily wire
we started in a pool house but the thing
that we knew is that we needed
to base our company's growth on data we
needed marketing
these were things that we focused on as
a company and thank god it's been very
successful well here's the thing
every company strives to have unique
values and a long lasting impact it's
time to position
your company as an industry leader
create buzz attracting customers
and generate consistent revenue giant
partners is here to help you do it
they're america's number one data-driven
marketing agency
giant partners operates in the
business-to-business space offering a
variety of business marketing solutions
like database marketing brand
development web design seo lead
generation
digital marketing services as well as ad
placement that's just to name a few of
the things they do
whether you own a small family business
or handle millions bucks in revenue
every year
giant partners can help you get to the
next level their marketing strategies
are research driven they're equipped
with 20 years of data experience
don't take my word for it their largest
customers include bmw ohio state
university
3m ethan allen head on over to
giantpartners.com right now to get your
business
set up today now nfts can be anything
they don't actually have to be a piece
of art so for example
jack dorsey that douchebag his first
tweet from his
cave in malaysia where he's being bitten
up by mosquitoes he tweeted out when he
first set up twitter
this would have been march 21 2006 just
setting up my twitter so this tweet went
for like 2.9 million in ethereum so
theoretically you could have a situation
in which somebody was paying for a
valueless tweet
with a valueless piece of currency but
in reality at least right now
ethereum is worth some money and so
somebody paid 2.9 million dollars for
this tweet now what does that mean
it doesn't mean that they have a license
to reproduce the tweet just like they
don't have a license to reproduce the
baseball card or to start producing
beanie babies it doesn't mean
that they are the exclusive owner of the
tweet in the sense that jack dorsey
has to take down the tweet and just give
it to them all it means is that people
now recognize
thanks to blockchain technology that
this is the original version of the
tweet
but you think oh that's stupid it's a
digital asset i can just reproduce it i
could just screen cap it go back on his
account
put it on yeah you can do the same thing
with a baseball card right you can do
the exact same thing with the mona lisa
you can get a print of the mona lisa
today you can print it out and you can
put it on your wall would it be the mona
lisa
no and if you say well you know that's
just because when you're talking about
the mona lisa
you know you're talking about the artist
having actually put his hands
on the paintbrush i mean that is a
distinction but it is a distinction
without a difference because again
baseball cards were mass-produced and
still hold their value it doesn't have
to actually be signed
by mickey mantle it's just produced by
the tops company so some of the prices
on these things are just
exorbitant and astounding so for example
this thing
i don't even know what this is this is
some sort of collage this thing the
original rights to this thing and again
not the right to
reproduce it or the right to distribute
it just the rights to the original
digital piece of artwork 69 million
dollars so for 69 million dollars
via christie's no now i guess that what
you do is you like put it on a
on a giant you project it on like a
giant screen in your house or something
i guess
to me the question is going to remain
the durability of this maybe this is
more durable than for example this
lindsay lohan piece of magnificent art
and look at that
is that lindsay lohan made this herself
so lindsay lohan aside from being
an absolutely stellar human with a ton
of artistic talent
uh she made this thing which is bitcoin
to the moon so apparently this sold for
like tens of thousands of dollars to
some sucker because i i don't think
there's gonna be a lot of artistic
durability to lindsay lohan pieces with
herbie the love bug now listen i can be
as puzzled as i want to be but somehow
little nos x has the number one song in
the country so people obviously have
very different cultural tastes from my
own some people just like horse
packaged as art but you know still i
understand why the normal person would
look at this and wonder why this is
worth money but then again
go look at a rothko painting i mean why
is that worth any money that's pretty
much my
my son's construction paper cutouts put
it on a piece of art and then just sold
for millions of dollars so you can't
question that some people put value in
art the good news is
that this means that the subjective
theory of value is true
which is good because it means that you
can't have actually a government
assigning value to particular objects on
the basis of some sort of
crazy algorithm or something that's
always going to fail the bad news is you
know people's bad taste sometimes is
rewarded with millions and millions of
dollars so there's been talk about fraud
and security when it comes to things
like nfts how do you guarantee that
nobody can actually duplicate it well
number one it is protected by blockchain
using the same sort of technology as
bitcoin
also fraud exists in the art world every
so often you'll hear a story where there
was a forgery of a great piece of art
and was sold for millions of dollars and
only later did somebody find out it was
a forgery
obviously easier to knock off a digital
image which can be
reproduced at will harder to replicate
the blockchain that actually establishes
its authenticity however
so do these things actually have
tangible value i mean the answer is
yes in the same way that your bank
account has tangible value you don't
actually have a stockpile of gold
in your house you don't actually have a
stack of dollars in your house you even
have a stack of dollars at the bank
these are all numbers on a piece of
paper we live in a digital world
nfts are just a reflection of the fact
that we live in a digital world and that
people
put value in digital assets in the same
way that they put value in tangible
physical assets
so in the end are nfts here to stay i
mean if the digital world is here to
stay and nfts are here to stay the
question is whether we are in an nft
bubble
and that certainly could be the case
when you've got stuff like this going
for almost a million bucks that seems
like an nft bubble to me
the other question i have to ask myself
is when do i just convert half of the
stuff i've done online to nfts and make
a bit of quick cash
i have to think about that here for
example
is the code on lindsay lohan and this
magnificent piece of art i mean look at
that it's just spectacular
look at that i mean that is that is what
i'd want to carry around in my wallet